un emotivo reencuentro los polacos
reciben a sus familiares ucranianos que
ahora son refugiados de guerra en médica
el paso fronterizo más concurrido de la
frontera polaca el éxodo de refugiados
es incesante más de 2 millones de
ucranianos se han cruzado a polonia
desde el inicio de la guerra hace casi
un mes y línea de 24 años es una de
ellas tomo fotos de la violencia que vio
el motivo por el que dejó todo atrás
porteña societá no hay agua no hay
electricidad no hay suministros de
comida solo pan y es poco todo está
cerrado
muchos de los refugiados aquí tienen
historias similares la mayoría se
enfrentan a un futuro incierto las
autoridades dicen que de los 2 millones
de ucranianos que han cruzado a polonia
poco más de la mitad 11 se han
establecido en el país personas como
daniel de 17 años que acaba de retomar
las clases después de que la invasión
rusa tumbar a sus estudios
cuando empezó la situación me fue muy
difícil centrarme en otras cosas pero el
tiempo pasó y ahora la situación es más
estable así como mi salud mental
la agencia de la onu para los refugiados
dice que el número de cruces diarios de
personas que huyen de la violencia en
ucrania ha disminuido en los últimos
días más de 3 millones de personas han
salido desde el inicio de la invasión
rusa además de polonia a países como
eslovaquia hungría rumanía y moldavia
han acogido a cientos de miles de
refugiados naciones unidas- había
estimado inicialmente que la guerra
obligaría a 4 millones de personas a
huir pero ahora dice que la cifra real
podría ser mucho mayor